JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
WHAT IS DAVOS, YOU ASK?
THE HOME OF THE WORLD ECONOMIC
FORUM WHERE WORLD LEADERS AND
BUSINESS EXECUTIVES DRINK
EXPENSIVE WINE, EAT FANCY MEAT,
AND THROW UP AND HOT TUBS AND
TELL US WHAT IS WRONG WITH US.
I WAS GOING TO GO BUT MY
GULFSTREAM HAS BEEN ACTING UP
AND MY MANSERVANT HAS AN
INFECTED UVULA.
THEY WON'T BE GIVING TRUMP A
WARM WELCOME.
AN ANGRY MOUNTAIN.
SWISS ACTIVISTS DID THAT, PRETTY
THEIR BIGGEST PROBLEM IS BEING
CONFUSED FOR SWEDEN.
IT'S NOT LIKE DONALD TRUMP
CARES.
IN FACT, THE ANGRIER THEY GET,
FIRST.
OUR ECONOMY IS ON FIRE, SO MUCH
SO THAT SWISS COULD WARM THEIR
WORKERS RAISES WORTH MILLIONS.
I GUESS THEY JUST WANT THE
AND BONUSES.
GREAT NEWS FOR YOU AND BAD NEWS
FOR THOSE VULNERABLE DEMOCRATS
UP FOR REELECTION WHO DIDN'T
CREDIT.
ALL THEY CAN HOPE FOR IS A
ROOTING FOR BAD NEWS SO YOU
MIGHT WIN.
MANY OF US ARE WEARING BURGUNDY.
NO REASON WHY.
ISN'T IT?
NOT A SECRET SOCIETY.
>> Greg: NO, DANA, I BET YOU
HAVE A THEORY ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
DOWN.
HIS FIRST DAY IN DAVOS, AND HE'S
DOING GREAT.
>> Dana: INDEED HE IS.
LOOKED TO ME LIKE HE WAS HAVING
A GOOD TIME.
WHAT?
HE HAS FRIENDS.
HE IS MAKING FRIENDS OR ON THE
I IMAGINE A TRUMP PRESIDENCY
WOULD BRING.
HE IS A DISRUPTOR AND MY THEORY,
IF STEVE BANNON WERE STILL IN
THE WHITE HOUSE ADVISING THE
PRESIDENT, I THINK THIS VISIT
WOULD LOOK VERY DIFFERENT.
THE TONE AND TENOR WOULD BE
DIFFERENT.
GO AND SAY HEY, I AM THE
HEAD COACH OF CAPITALISM.
INTO HIGHER GEAR.
I GET THE "AMERICA FIRST," NOT
"AMERICA ALONE" THING.
REALITY HAS SET IN.
FOR A LONG TIME THEY THOUGHT
PRESIDENT TRUMP REALLY DOESN'T
WANT TO BE PRESIDENT OR HE
DOESN'T REALLY WANT TO RUN
THE CAMPAIGNS, AND THAT THEY ARE
FIGURING OUT A WAY TO WORK WITH
THEM.
THEY WERE THERE WAS A ROUNDTABLE
HE DID WITH BUSINESS LEADERS AND
THEY WERE ALL LIKE, WE'VE GOT TO
INVEST IN THE UNITED STATES WE
ARE PLANNING TO INCREASE IT.
PRETTY SOON COME ALL OF THESE
COMPANIES.
THERE IS BE SOMEBODY -- SO MANY
COMPANIES AMERICA ANNOUNCING
BONUSES SO IF YOU ARE AN OUTLIER
AND YOU HAVE NOT ANNOUNCED
BONUSES, THAT WILL BECOME
SOMETHING.
[LAUGHTER]
NOT BONUSES FOR PEOPLE LIKE YOU,
JESSE.
>> Kimberly: YOU ARE UNDER
CONTRACT.
>> Dana: IT IS EASIER TO SAY
WHICH COMPANIES HAVEN'T DONE IT?
TO BE COMPANIES ARE STILL
TRICKLE-DOWN ECONOMICS AND PEER
ELSE.
HOW CAN YOU NOT DENY THE CAUSE
AND EFFECT.
IT'S HAPPENING.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT
NOT COMING THE TOP DOWN.
GROWING OUT.
THEY ARE GETTING CHECKS FOR
$5,000, REINVESTING IN AMERICA.
>> Dana: ALSO THEY LOWERED
ENERGY COSTS AND SEVERAL
DIFFERENT UTILITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: SOME COMPANIES ARE
THROWING MONEY INTO COLLEGE
FUNDS FOR THE WORKERS AND THINGS
WINNING.
I DON'T SEE HOW THEY DO IT.
HOW CAN YOU DENY YOUR 401(K)
EXPLODING?
HOW CAN YOU DENY TAX CUTS?
THEY ARE LIKE CLIMATE DENIERS.
THERE WINNING DENIERS.
IT IS SO EASY, AND YOU COULD SEE
IT COMING FROM A MILE AWAY, YET
NOT ONE DEMOCRAT VOTED FOR THE
CORPORATE TAX CUT IN THE
DEREGULATION.
GO SUPER NEGATIVE TRY TO BRING
OUT WOMEN, BLACKS COMMAND
LATINOS WHICH ONLY SHE -- WHICH
DON'T USUALLY TURN OUT IN THE
MIDTERMS.
>> Greg: I AM STEALING WINNING
DENIERS FOR MY SHOW ON SATURDAY.
JUAN COME I WANT TO PLAY A
THOUGHT FROM ANOTHER NETWORK.
I KNOW.
YOU HAVE TO HELP THESE PEOPLE
OUT.
NOBODY'S WATCHING.
THIS IS THEIR TAKE ON TRUMP AND
DALLOS.
THEM WOMEN.
WHEN I LOOK AT PRESIDENT TRUMP
RIGHT THERE, I MENTIONED THE
PEOPLE WITH HIM, HE HAS
BLANKED -- THERE IS ONE, BY
RACE ON THE BRAIN.
NOTHING BUT WHITE MEN.
CLEARLY THIS IS A RACIST
GATHERING.
MUST BE STOPPED.
ALMOST AN ALT-RIGHT OF EDGE.
I THINK THE ECONOMY IS GOING
GREAT.
I THINK EVERYBODY'S EXCITED.
IT'S WONDERFUL BUT IF YOU ARE
SAYING THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW GOOD
THERE ARE SO MANY, BUT CHINA IS
OBVIOUSLY DOING MUCH BETTER.
THEN YOU GO INTO EUROPE.
A >> Jesse: BECAUSE WORKERS
GET PAID PENNIES.
>> Juan: ALL RIGHT, NOW WE ARE
MAKING EXCUSES AGAIN.
>> Jesse: IT IS REALITY.
IT IS SLAVE LABOR.
>> Juan: YOU ARE SAYING THE THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY IS BOOMING.
THE SECOND THING, A MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS CREDIT
PRESIDENT OBAMA, NOT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Greg: ARE THEY REALLY
AMERICANS?
>> Juan: OH, I SEE, ANYONE WHO
DISAGREE WITH TRUMP IS NOT
UN-AMERICAN.
FAKE FAKE NEWS, FAKE NEWS.
THIS MORNING, THE PAPERS HAVE
REPUBLICANS REBELLING AGAINST
TRUMP BECAUSE HE IS RAISING
TARIFFS.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING DON'T DO IT.
DON'T FORGET, THE FARMERS AND
OTHERS.
>> Dana: THEY ARE NOT HAPPY.
>> Juan: THE IDEA TO BREAK
APART AND AFTER, BREAK APART
TRADE DEALS.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHAT MAKES
>> Juan: I AM SAYING THERE IS
A LOT MORE TO THIS STORY ABOUT
THE ECONOMY AND THE IDEA THAT HE
CAN RUN ON THE ECONOMY,
CREDIT DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S NOT GOOD NEWS FOR
LONG THEY ARE ABLE TO TRY TO
CREATE AN ALTERNATE REALITY.
NOT ACCEPT THE DONALD TRUMP HAS
DONE QUITE A BIT HERE.
HE'S GOT A HOUSING REBOUND.
THE ECONOMY IS ACCELERATING.
JOB NUMBERS UP, INFRASTRUCTURE
UP.
A LOT OF POSITIVE THINGS
HAPPENING THAT YOU CREDIT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, INCLUDING THE
CORPORATE TAX CUTS.
REPUBLICANS HAVE SOMETHING TO
WORK WITH IN TERMS OF THESE
MIDTERM RACES.
HE'S IN A GOOD POSITION.
PARTICIPATING IN SHOWING UP.
BUT HE HAS WINS ON HIS SIDE.
COMING STRONG OUT OF THE BATTLE
WITH SCHUMER AND DACA.
THIS IS A VERY POSITIVE POSITION
SAYING, I THINK THE THEME OF THE
WHOLE THING IS FRACTURED WORLD
BUT WE HAVE A SHARED FUTURE IN
TERMS OF THE GLOBAL ECONOMY.
SO THEY ARE GOING AHEAD IN TERMS
OF TRADE DEALS.
THEY ARE GOING TERMS OF TRYING
TO WORK TOGETHER MULTILATERALLY.
MEANWHILE, TRUMP AS THEY ARE
SAYING OH, NO, THIS IS ABOUT
BILATERAL AGREEMENTS WITH THE
UNITED STATES AND HE IS SAYING
WE ARE PUTTING THE U.S. FIRST
AND WE ARE ABOUT ISOLATIONISM,
IF NOT PROTECTIONISM.
THAT'S NOT A HAPPY MESSAGE.
>> Jesse: WHAT AMUSES ME, WHEN
THE LEFT SAYS TRUMP IS GOING TO
CRASH THE ECONOMY.
THEN THE ECONOMY ACCELERATES AND
THEY SAY OBAMA GETS CREDIT FOR
IT.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAY THAT.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE GET A $1,000
BONUS CHECK IN JANUARY 2010, HOW
IS THAT OBAMA?
>> Greg: THE LATEST POLLS ARE
40% BELIEVE THE ECONOMY IS
BETTER HAS TO DO WITH TRUMP AND
THE OTHERS ARE SPLIT.
THERE IS NO MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS.
>> Dana: FOR REPUBLICANS IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY ARE
IMPROVING IN THE LAST FOUR
WEEKS.
PART OF THAT IS THE GOOD
HEADLINES.
I HAVE A COUPLE POINTS.
ONE IS THAT FOR DEMOCRATS WHO
DIDN'T VOTE FOR THESE TAX CUTS
AND TAX REFORM, THIS COULD HAVE
BEEN THEIRS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA DID WANT TO CUT
THAT BUT IT WOULDN'T BUDGE ON
INDIVIDUAL RATES.
HE WANTED TO INCREASE TAXES ON
THE RIDGE.
ALL OF THIS COULD'VE BEEN THEIRS
AND THE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
ANNOUNCED BONUSES, IMAGINE WHAT
THEY WOULD'VE DONE TO BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO TRY TO HELP.
HOUR.
THAT WAS DONE WITHOUT THE
GOVERNMENT TELLING THEM THEY HAD
TO.
THAT'S ANOTHER WAY FOR
CONSERVATIVES TO SAY THAT THE
MARKET WORKS.
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY
THAT'S GOOD FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
DO IS AS HE MEETS WITH THESE
WORLD LEADERS, THERESA MAY,
MACRON, AND ALSO OF RWANDA,
THERE'S GOING TO BE A TIME WHEN
HE WILL HAVE TO ASK ONE OF THESE
WORLD LEADERS FOR A FAVOR OR
HELP AND IT WILL BE POLITICALLY
UNPOPULAR IN THEIR COUNTRY TO DO
IT.
BUT IF HE HAS PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEM, IT'S
MORE LIKELY THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
PONY UP.
>> Greg: THAT IS A SALESMAN.
ALLOWED TO HAVE ACTIVISTS.
IF THEY ARE NEUTRAL -- IF THEY
ARE NEUTRAL, THEY ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO PLAY.
THAT IS LIKE DEALING YOURSELF AT
A BLACKJACK TABLE WITHOUT ANY
IF YOU ARE NEUTRAL, YOU CAN'T
PROTEST, HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T READ A LOT.
>> Jesse: SWITZERLAND OR
SWEDEN?
>> Greg: I GET THEM CONFUSED.
ONE OF THEM YODEL.
THE SWEDES FISH.